hey everyone deolo here and today we are
jumping into a completely different
series that I've seen a bunch of you
requesting down below solo leveling is
one of those Journeys where we follow
one man on his quest to become the
strongest in a constant battle against
both man and monsters unlike a bunch of
manga that I Shan name this Mana doesn't
stray into the confusing philosophical
or profound instead it's extremely easy
to read and lets the art along with the
brilliant fight scenes take a hold don't
get me wrong this story also has a great
deal of substance and interesting
Concepts they just don't make that the
overall focus of the story itself the
focus is always seemingly on Jin wo and
his quest to become the strongest in
this video we're going to cover the
first Arc that takes place throughout
the series d rank dungeon Arc this Arc
is a fantastic way to enter the world of
solo leveling while focusing on the main
character his initial strengths and
weaknesses we slowly fed information
that allows us to gain an even greater
understanding of the world that everyone
finds themselves in it seems to be one
like our own however 10 years earlier a
random event led to a massive change in
the world if you want to find out more
subscribe push this video to 3K likes so
I know that you all want the next Arc
and sit back and relax as we delve into
the first part of solo
leveling kicking things off in Soul
South Korea apologies toong for what's
probably a terrible accent for a Korean
pronunciation either way we find the
world's weakest Hunter e rank s Jan Wu
walking through these streets br ing
over his ridiculously weak self JY finds
it embarrassing to even call himself a
hunter being a hunter is a job where you
place your life on the line in the hopes
of great return however JY isn't doing
this because it's his choice meanwhile
in a construction site the infamously
noan weakest Hunter S Jin Wu arrives to
join the other hunters in a raid looking
over at him walk past one returning
Hunter bark questions if he's powerful
as everyone is happy to see him Kim
though points out that it's actually the
opposite he's the world's weakest and
finds it tough to even get through an e-
rank dungeon figuring that since he's
here it's most likely an extremely weak
dungeon Kim tells his boy to quiet his
voice since he might overhear them
talking to which it's revealed that Jin
had actually heard the entire
conversation trying to clear his mind JY
asks for a coffee however to his dismay
finds out that they just run out feeling
absolutely terrible about this the
Barista apologizes to Jin as he walks
off a bit L down all of a sudden Je
screams out noticing that he's all
beaten up sitting down together the two
chat for a brief moment about how Jen
was sent to hospital following an
expedition into an e- rank dungeon
getting up Jen tells her that they might
as well head over since it looks like
everyone is about to head in gathering
everyone around song CH asks if it's all
right to take the role as team leader
for this raid everyone agrees and
shortly following this he HS inside
telling everyone to follow him forth
into the dungeon gaining confidence Jin
Wu tells himself to try his best today
and enters the portal last behind
everyone else watching everyone leave in
front of him the dude from the coffee
stand tells his boy that he feels a bit
sh since he wasn't able to give jyn a
coffee before he headed in now in the
dungeon Jin Woo is found already being
healed by jei and apologizing for his
lack of skills all around them the other
members of the group take care of the
remaining monsters thinking that the
raid is almost done now Jin wo looks
over to see everyone in a group talking
above their heads you can see a symbol
representing something these different
colors and symbols each correlate to a
member's Affinity snapping him back ji
asks if he has a reason one stopping him
from leaving not wanting to reveal his
own personal hell Jin L while expressing
that he does this for the fun of it
otherwise he'd actually die of boredom
nearby song holding a crystal in his
hand explains that this thing is a
magical core an item someone receives
after killing a monster magical cores
from even a c rank monster is worth
thousands yet sadly since JY is an e-
rank Hunter C ranks are a mere
impossibility for him to achieve holding
the pathetic e- rank core in his hand JY
thinks it's a bit small after putting
his all into this dungeon as he becomes
even more disheartened a random yells
out that they found another entrance
standing in front of the gaping cave
entrance now song explains that the
thing in front of them is most likely a
double Lear sparking up his magical
Flames song beautifully twists torrent
of fire and shoots it forth a distance
down the tunnel watching it continue
through the air the flame hits the
ground before slowly fading Back to
Black getting everyone's attention song
elaborates that the gate actually won't
close if the boss is still alive due to
the gate not closing yet it's evident
that the boss is most likely down the
tunnel usually they need to contact the
guild but if other people get the
profits first then their own profits
will dwindle looking at all of them he
instead proposes a vote on if they
should Venture forth to kill the boss
since there are 17 of them it will
result in one side winning and no matter
what they shouldn't complain about what
happens after a few moments it's shown
that the votes came back 8 to8 with it
all depending on Jin Wu's vote if they
Venture forth knowing who doesn't have
enough money and soon needs to pay for
his sister to attend college plus look
after his sick mother in hospital Jin Wu
announces that he is going meaning that
all 17 of the hunters will push further
into the dungeon wondering how long it's
been since everyone entered the cave
someone mentions that it's been around
40 minutes and the gate will close an
hour after the boss is defeated so right
now they have about 20 minutes spare to
escape walking together Jen wo
apologizes to jei for forcing her to
come in here after voting yes being told
he doesn't need to worry Jen pushes
further to get the truth only for jei to
rage out and tell him that no she
currently is not okay screaming if he's
mental ji reveals that the wound Jinn
initially received the one that you know
we never saw him get was a stair wound
that entered just below where his heart
is coming to see that he really is only
alive because of her Jen apologizes for
dragging her into this once more smiling
ji hints that if he really is sorry
maybe he should take her out for some
food to prove it blushing but unable to
say anything Jui asks him if he doesn't
want to to which he snaps out of the
days and accepts the date finally after
a few more minutes the group end up
finding a large golden EMP purple door
asking those following if they want to
return empty-handed or not song begins
pushing the door open while saying that
they could be the first ones to Iver
into this section creaking open the door
and entering the room blue flames ignite
Al lighting the room and revealing the
large circular space that lays before
them expecting to face magical beasts
the team is confused and notes that it
looks as if no one has been here in ages
statues surround the room some holding
weapons some holding instruments the
atmosphere makes jyn's hair stand on
edge and he feels as if someone is
literally staring down on him not
wanting to be caught up with negative
feelings Jen examines the massive statue
that's seated in the center back of the
room he assumes it isn't the boss as
it's only a statue however it's the only
one this large by the way all the other
statues in the room like in the light
novel they're actually only as tall as
all of the people as well or like
slightly taller than all of the people
in the room they're not massive like
statues like we see here the only
massive one is meant to be the one of
the cheer but you know obviously things
change from web comic to you know like
the light novel and everything anyways
anyways Looking Down song randomly finds
a moss covered magic seal yelling out to
him another of the crew calls him over
to read some ancient text moving over to
the text board song begins reading out
Karin's Temple Commandments first
Worship the Lord second praise the Lord
third prove your faith being tapped on
the shoulder J turns around to hear jei
exclaiming that the statue's eyeball
just moved thinking that she's got to be
tripping suddenly Jen starts to feel an
aura he hadn't before the ear became
chill and all noise stopped with that
song announces to the group that anyone
who does not follow the previously
mentioned rules will never return alive
slamming behind them everyone's heads
snap back to see the previously open
entrance is slammed shot annoyed with
everyone's spouting nonsense one of the
team members announces that you know
he's out of here they can have whatever
Treasures they find but he's done
wishing them good luck he places his
hand upon the door only to hear song
Scream out for him to wait before his
voice even reaches the hunter a shadow
shoots through the room and cleaves the
man down instantly following this the
statue returns to its position and
lowers the weapon horrified to witness
the statue come to life the team members
are all left speechless knowing that if
they want to leave they need to destroy
these statues Jin wo remembering a
previous statement flexs his head around
to see the main statue now staring right
back at him thinking about the guy who
just died Jen knows he was only d rank
even if he was only a weak d rank he
still would have been stronger than an
e- rank like himself for like obviously
those who are confused with the ranking
system inside of solo leveling simply it
starts with e then it goes up from there
with d c b a and then finally the
strongest at East rank the enemy has
done things slightly differently as you
could tell not with like the power
system or anything like that instead
it's added a few other interactions with
characters that never happened in these
initial chapters I think it was like
like a like a pre- chapter or something
I haven't actually read it before so I
don't know I think it's good cuz it kind
of like expands the world a little bit
more and shows us that other things are
happening at the same time while this is
also going on however I do hope that A1
which is the studio that is taking on so
the leveling here sticks with mainly
Jen's point of view like we get
throughout the story or get throughout
the web comic and doesn't get too caught
up in other things too early on the
pacing right now is looking like four to
five chapters per episode so I'm
assuming over the 12 episodes we're
probably going to get around 55 to 60
chapters possibly even more throughout
this first season it just depends on how
the pacing is for like other arcs and
everything but that's kind of like how
I'm feeling right now anyways anyways
confused because this dungeon was meant
to be d rank at most JY swears that he's
never heard of monsters as strong as
these inside of a d rank dungeon any
flashback we find that this wasn't the
first time JY almost died during the
first raid he ever went on he
accidentally left the group and got lost
then out of nowhere a random e- rank
Goblin shanked him from behind sending
him straight to the hospital for weeks
another time he almost starved to death
after being trapped inside because his
entire team had left other people in
like the solo leveling World usually use
their magical CES to trade up for be
weapons to then fight stronger monsters
and earn even more money Jin however
can't do this he he never holds a weapon
so like that little blade you do see in
the anime as well I don't think that
ever happens it would just break anyway
like he says right here having a Healer
means that his injuries are able to get
healed but only if it wasn't too extreme
though that means that that healer has
to work twice as hard babysitting some
weight clean who can actually barely
look after himself every time JY got
injured and heard this snaring remarks
all the times he continued a job that
may result in his demise maybe it was
all for this one moment here reacting
just in time Jin Wu screams out for all
of his comrades to duck hearing his
warning some Hunters stand there
stationary watching the statue's eyes
begin to Glow suddenly a beam of light
is sent out that utterly eviscerates
anything in its path opening their eyes
and seeing what remains of the group The
Hunter's horror only furthers as they
notice that a large portion of them were
taken out with a single blast making
himself heard song yells for everyone to
not stand up and remain in their
positions if they if they choose to
stand back up now the statue will 100%
attack them again with everyone
listening song creeps over to Jin and
lets him know that even though jei is a
b rank healer she can't handle fear at
all while talking with song JY notices
that almost all of his fellow Hunter's
arm was blown off by the previous attack
asking to be bandaged up song looks up
at the giant statue and questions his
boy about what rank it looks like it
could be to him not knowing juice like
never having even stepped a foot in a
dungeon High d rank song who's you know
actually somewhat experienced and has
been in a b rank dungeon a few times as
certain that this Bean definitely
exceeds that of a b rank boss this one
he guesses that it could possibly even
be an srank creature thinking on the
spot Jen remembers the Commandments that
song had read out earlier Worship the
Lord praise the Lord and prove your
faith those who do not follow the
Commandments will never return alive to
JY it's obvious he thinks that the giant
Godlike statue seated in front of him is
that Lord in Solo leveling these
dungeons exist in a different time space
or Dimension to get there something
called a gate is needed to be used this
gate is a sort of tunnel that connects
other random worlds to their own 10
years earlier after the first gate
randomly appeared in the world many
people began to experience random events
one of these random events to happen
with the modification of humans into
Hunters the moment a hunter is chosen
their strength stays the same and it is
impossible to change
Jin 2 became a hunter however his
strength was only enough for an e- rank
rating still Jin is stronger than most
individuals it's just that the
difference between him and other ranks
is extremely drastic the men and woman
who received the powers to cross the
gate and Destroy monsters as a career
were labeled as Hunters sometimes on odd
occasions beyond the gate there can be
an ominous despairing insane monster
that comes out of absolutely nowhere
wondering if he's going to be okay JY
asks if song's bleeding will stop but
song says there really isn't much he can
do about it now initially he'd brought
three heers here because he thought this
would be over quickly now one literally
got vaporized by the first attack and
the other is so shocked that he's unable
to move even the B rank healer Chui has
never experienced anything like this so
it's making healing slightly difficult
for the time being for song he thinks
that the best course of action is to
stand still then once the situation
clear is a tad try and make a run for it
suddenly one of the random Hunters
breaks away from the group while
claiming that this isn't his final
moment he finally managed to join a big
Guild so he won't die here ging his
teeth the man gases himself up and plans
to use enough speed to burst through the
doors in an instant boosting off and
seeing rocks flying with tremendous
speed the hunter begins closing in on
the door all of a sudden though a burst
of light shoots through the room
evaporating the Hunter and leaving
nothing but his feet remaining groaning
with rage another another Hunter
questions why it is that the monsters
are taking their time when they could
just take them out whenever they feel
like it thinking that this is completely
different from the typical monsters who
just blindly attack on site JY is able
to deduce that the statues seem to
attack in a sort of pattern snapping his
head back towards something he figures
that it has to be there has to be a rule
to how this room Works analyzing the
Commandments of Caron Jin realizes that
this is the key to surviving the room
asking what the first commandment was
song reminds him that it was to Worship
the Lord pondering what this could
possibly mean JY starts to get up while
explaining that there was a rule to this
dungeon making his way over towards the
statue Jen watches as the eyes begin to
glow and immediately drops to the floor
switch starting to drip from his brow
seeing the glow and the eyes fade he
assumes that the beam will start to
attack if the targeted person moves past
a specific height understanding an
aspect of the statue now Jen Wu tells
everyone to bow down before it wondering
if he's gone mad or something song asks
if he's managed to figure something out
replying yes Jin explains that like I've
said the bean attacks those who move
past a certain height the phrase Worship
the Lord literally means Bow Down and
Worship Him following the e- ranker
orders everyone bows down and begins
worshiping the statue in front of them
looking down on them the light from the
statue's eyes randomly disappears
snapping open the concrete grin of this
grotesque being over opens up and its
eyes turn red ominously looking down on
all of the fodder Hunters below it
feeling its gaze violating them Jen
wonders how many this creature has
attacked in the past how many people in
their group are still alive how long do
they have to lay down here and do this
in front of this thing starting to rise
back up to his feet bark starts to think
that the creature stopped and instead of
continuing to make them bow will try
something else soon he doubts that just
because they bowed down everything is
going to turn out fine one by one
everyone slowly begins Rising back to
their feet after seeing that the monster
has indeed stopped attacking suddenly
the room begins to shake and the statue
itself begins rising from the seat
stomping on the floor everyone looks up
in horror knowing that this entire
Fiasco isn't over towering above them
like a monolithic demonic God all of the
hunters stand there in fear unable to
move or say anything stepping forth song
screams at Jin for any more ideas but
due to the frantic nature of the dungeon
he's unable to think of anything quickly
snapping out of it he remembers the
roles that he started going over earlier
knowing that the next line of
Commandments was to praise the Lord Jen
guesses that it has to be the key to
solving this speaking up another random
Hunter announces that he's got this back
in the day he was a member of a church
choir so his lungs are literally built
for praising grabbing a hold of his
cross the hunter closes his eyes and
starts to approach the Lord not stopping
under fear of death the hunter sings for
the Lord to make him a new as everyone
stands around they wonder if it's
working or not and bark even thinks that
the creatures started to move slightly
slower now Jin though man's dripping in
a cold sweat since he's come to realize
it the hunter is actually praying to the
wrong god with that the statue steps
down flattening the ex- Christian below
its gigantic foot screaming and turning
away in fear of the seemingly inevitable
some of the people even decide to start
running away in hopes of living for just
a moment longer tifi and unable to move
ji screams her final words as the statue
squishes her as well JK though big sing
chin was able to double back and quickly
tear her away in time running now song
tells everyone to split up in an attempt
to figure out what to do next by himself
Buck thinks back on his wife and the
life that he had with his family while
reiterating that he cannot die here he's
determined to be a father to his two
children but this is thinking he finally
found a safe location to chill out Kim
screams out for his mate to watch his
back and turn around unable to react in
time the statue cleaved downwards
slicing our boy buck in two and sending
them straight into the shadow realm just
like before the statue then returns to
its original position over the other
side of the room Jen runs with jei from
the statue wondering how the hell he's
meant to praise a God he doesn't even
know analyzing the room he knows that
the entire place is in circled with
large guards and a colossal statue
centered at the back if one gets too
close to a statue it automatically
attacks them in an instant randomly as
he looks at each individual statue he
sees a woman holding a trumpets
wondering if they attack with
instruments as well Jen knows the others
only attack if you get too close once
you are close it's all a predetermined
move set figuring that he's probably on
the right track here Jen yells out to
the remaining people to run towards
these statues with instruments seeing
that he was already next to One S looks
over to see the statue begin playing a
dank Chun backing up Jin statement he
tells the others that the statues
holding instruments do not attack
finding a statue of his own Kim breaks
down over the loss of his close friend
bark honestly it's pretty rough for the
man dude decided to return to the hunter
life only to get literally wreck rolled
by some demonic Gods little game in his
first dungeon back it's that's that's so
that's the worst RNG you could possibly
have sprinting over to the other side of
the room both chin and jei stand
underneath a manly drum however it
refuses to begin playing until only one
remains dting off JY makes a Mad Dash
towards the next closest instrument
looking over at the fleeing rat beneath
itself the statue then moves to stomp on
Jen telling himself to push just like
tar further Jen is able to dodge the
foot that goes to stomp down on him
however the subsequent stomp sends him
uncontrollably tumbling forwards stunned
and unable to move Jen can only watch as
he slides straight towards a shield
wielding statue thrusting downwards the
statue seemingly pushes its shield into
the ground and destroys the concrete
floor as Jin slides into it ji screams
out in a hope that he somehow made it
out alive bloody and barely able to move
now Jen pleads with whatever force is
above for something to appear in front
of him rising to his feet and holding on
to the thread that connects him to life
or death he slowly starts to feel like
now even that line may break closing his
eyes for the impending doom that's about
to happen the voice of an Angel suddenly
begins singing out below it we see that
our boy laid out has somehow managed to
get lucky and find a statue laughing at
the luck he seems to have we then see
that due to all of the music being
played or song being sung the Lord
statue has stopped dead in the center of
the room moments later jei Sprints over
to JY and asks him if he's all right JY
tries telling her that he's all right
however after arriving and seeing the
terrible state that he's currently in
missing a foot jei breaks down crying
feeling terrible and probably thinking
it's her fault that Jen lost his foot
Joi puts all her effort into making sure
that his wound is healed outp putting
too much magic though blood spurts from
her nose and she collapses next to jyn
thankful that at least jyn somehow
managed to survive can points out how
the group's numbers are quickly being
whittled away from 17 to only six and
two of those surviving members are
already Gravely injured finding it
unfortunate that song lost his arm Kim
reminds him that this is all because he
made a rash decision as the party leader
warning him about the impending
punishment for losing so many members
song heavy-hearted agrees with what he's
saying moving once more everyone's
attention is quickly brought back to the
Statue raising its left hand everyone
feels the ground shake uncontrollably
before in front of them a table- likee
object bursts through the floor once the
summoned platform finishes moving Flames
then ought to appear in the sky around
the outskirts of the room looking at the
summoning in front of them Kem wonders
what it could be only for Jen to say
that it's an altar elaborating to the
other five members he assumes it's one
from like an ancient mythology where
they sacrificed living beings for their
lord backing up his assumption he
reiterates that the final commandment
was to prove your faith suddenly a light
appears in the stomach of Kim and the
man begins withdrawing a blade from a
small Gateway like opening even though
he thinks he's dumb Kim understands that
this likely means they need to sacrifice
someone pointing his sword towards the
Gravely injured song Kim demands that
the man who brought them here steps
forwards in his mind Kim feels like song
is responsible for all 11 deaths that
have happened so far plus he also just
agreed to take responsibility for them
before seeing where he's coming from
song agrees on taking responsibility but
asks for him to lower the sword and let
him walk freely ahead behind them Jen
fullon disagrees with what's going on in
his mind he doesn't think it's his fault
they all technically voted to come in
here and it's just cowardly to turn
around and say it's his issue now
stumbling up to the altar though song
stares down at the weirdly decorated
pattern on top of it randomly a normal
flame ignites behind him causing Kim to
scream out and ask what the hell is
happening now confused Jin asks if this
isn't what they were supposed to do
unable to understand what the flame
means or if the God wanted a sacrifice
to start with Jin asks the four
remaining people in front of him if they
could also carry him up to the altar
being carried in by the large guy and
other female JY notices that as soon as
they enter the circle three more Flames
ignited asking song if he thinks the
others will save them if they decide to
stay here song begins explaining a
feature of how these Gates actually work
for them right now it marks one week
since the gate was opened the statues
will start moving before reinforcements
even get to this part of the dungeon the
reason this even matters is because
after one week of a dungeon being open
monsters inside of the gate can actually
come through and enter their own world
the entire purpose of a raid to begin
with is to kill the boss and close the
gate before the time runs out if the
people inside of the dungeon fail these
tasks right now it will mean the
monsters commanding them to do all these
random tasks can freely into their own
world turning to the final two members
Jen tells them that they should come
here as well for every person that steps
on the altar a flame appears and he
thinks that the trial won't begin until
everyone's here listening to him and
proceeding to stand on the altar
themselves blue lights suddenly shoot
along the ground out to the outer edge
of the altar where it likes a
corresponding blue flame looking at the
ant-sized people below it the statue
waves its hand once more causing the
door over the other side of the room to
swing open standing there stunned
everyone wonders what the hell they
should do now adding to the already
intense situation every stone statue
around the circumference of the room
slowly begins enclosing in on the group
randomly jyn looks from statue to Statue
and sees the movement say least the
moment his eyes look at them turning to
jei he tells her that she cannot close
her eyes here it's just like when they
were kids the statues will only move
when you take your eyes off them kind of
like the coil heads from lethal company
but the movement speed is absolutely
nerfed anyways anyways closing her eyes
in fear and listening to the Statue take
another step the other female Hunter
screams out in Terror before darting off
in an attempt to escape once she leaves
the circle one of the Flames around the
outside of the altar vanish and she
seemingly runs through the doorway
unharmed absolutely confused with what
the hell they just witnessed everyone
questions jyn how she's still alive Plus
on top of that when she did exit the
door it slightly closed trying to think
Jin presumes a blue flame will disappear
after a set amount of time one of the
red Flames that appeared based on the
number of people also vanished the
moment she left the circle due to how
straightforward the rules have been so
far Jen comes to the conclusion that the
door is a trap a false hope the door
only opened opened after the red Flames
appeared and closes just slightly every
time one of the same Flames disappear
prove your faith for Jin as literal
meaning that even in Terror and danger
with the sweetest of Temptations keep
your faith true apologizing to Jenn
though the big dude who carried him over
earlier says he doesn't think he can
take much more of this throwing Jin to
the floor and leaving him helpless the
man runs off towards a supposed false
hope watching another leave in front of
him Kim is just baffled that once again
someone ran out screaming out that no
one can move though Jen explains that if
anyone else decides to leave and they're
only stuck with three people the rest
will not be able to survive needing an
elaboration on what's Happening song
asks Jen for more info to what she tells
them that all they need to do is stay
still and watch the statues until the
blue flames disappear the blue flames
are a timer and once they run out
everyone will be able to leave freely
Kim tells them that yeah he may be right
but the door could also just slam shut
sealing them in here when the blue
flames run out as well throughout all of
the previous dungeons he's gone through
with Jen Kim never imagined someone as
weak as him would be helpful he always
looked down on him and never really
expected anything from him a lot of
people initially died when they got here
but the ones who are alive are because
of his quick thinking Kim thanks him for
everything so far however as he throws
his sword to the ground begins tearing
up he reveals he also has a family and
doesn't want to die just yet not being
able to take the fear of death anymore
Kim apologizes one more time before
leaving the circle and making a run for
Freedom with tears in his eyes JY drops
to the floor utterly pissed off with
everyone's apparent selfishness now that
Kim's run the remaining three have no
chance it's doomed them to a cruel death
looking defeated about what's just
happened song points out that the door
is nearly closed it's too late now but
he finally understands what what's
actually going on knowing that the door
won't close as long as there's at least
one person on the altar song tells the
others to leave since they naturally
have a lot more Life to Live turning to
jei he asks if she'd be able to help Jen
out of the room to what she instantly
agrees sadly though jei collapses to the
floor before she's even able to attempt
picking Jen up seeing her legs shaking
jei cries out that they won't move at
all sadly and due to jei using too much
Mana in an attempt to heal Jen previous
ly she's exhausted herself to the point
that she can no longer move herself
which means that two of them are now
incapacitated taking the old dude's
Place JY tells him that he should
instead take Jui out of here disagreeing
song tries saying that he'll stay but
obviously Jen points out that no one
will be able to carry jei plus there's
no time they need to run screaming out
she'd rather stay here Jen reminds her
that he promised he'd buy you he dinner
sometime pulling out his pathetic e rank
core JY tells her to eat the dinner
first then once he returns he'll find
her for that payment going to say
something ji is sadly and quickly
knocked out as song picks her up and
tells JY there really isn't any more
time to wait asking the old man to take
care of her song promises that he will
before slowly making his leave with je
he seeing them Escape through the door
to safety Jen thanks God as at least
he's the only one that's dying now it's
an interesting aspect like think about
how in like that moment there he weirdly
Praises God thanking him that he's the
the only one who's dying here I don't
know it's just something that I've
noticed as I've begun scripting the
series and it's almost unintentional
from his side but I'm curious as to if
it held any Credence in the actual story
itself I assume that it didn't and it's
probably just words feeling like an
idiot anyway Jen beats himself up over
not having got a life insurance in case
of this happening looking over and
seeing Kim sort on the ground he picks
it up and decides that in his final
moments he's going to at least take one
of these monsters down with him
bloodshot eyes and completely unable to
stand due to his missing foot Jin points
his blade forth and tells the monster to
come it's an interesting thing to ask a
monster to do but either way and he
Flash the closest monster strikes down
on Jin ripping through his chest with a
complete ease coughing blood and
screaming in pain the monster doesn't
stop instead it removes its spear
flinging Jin up into the a falling down
now at top The Altar and barely
breathing our boy exclaims that he
doesn't want to he doesn't want to die
tears pour from his eyes and thoughts
begin to rush his mind this isn't fine
what do you mean thankful done with
everything he questions why everyone
betrayed him he also has a family he
also doesn't want to die remembering he
said that he's glad he's the only one
dying Jin tells himself he's a freaking
liar he he never wanted to die now
laying there and watching his life come
to its close chin wishes that he had
just one more chance striking downwards
suddenly the altar erupts with a paora
of different lights and Flames the blade
from the statue slowly begins to come to
a stop until it ceases stuck in time
confused he wonders what the hell this
could be looking closer the random
screen reads alarm you sir are dank and
have completed all necessary
requirements of this secret Quest
courage of the weak still acting blazed
cuz dude's got a hole in his chest and
probably can't really even read the
screen correctly Jin can't seem to even
comprehend what just happened suddenly
another screen pops up asking if he will
accept the right to become a player then
another reminding him that he doesn't
have much time at all remaining if he
actually refuses this random request
then his heart will stop approximately
0.02 seconds after realizing that if he
accepts he doesn't need to die Jin takes
it welcoming him as a player Jin's
bruise cut and limp body is suddenly
engulfed by beams of light so bright
that he's physically hidden from view I
guess that is one way to end the first
Arc of the series on a more or less
Cliffhanger which like we all know
dude's absolutely fine otherwise I don't
know what all this like finished light
novel jargon or the almost 100 chapters
of a web tune would be about though it
would be pretty funny if man killed his
main character at chapter 10 then
decided to recreate him funnily enough I
guess in a way he kind of does do that
like man was 0.02 seconds off dying and
well you've seen what comes next man's a
completely different person speaking of
next if you have all enjoyed this d rank
dungeon art for solo leveline then
please make sure to push this video to
3,000 likes so I know you all want more
and check out the web comic for
yourselves it's honestly a really really
easy read no brain power at all needed
it's just the typical brute hype Fist
and I love that it's it's absolutely
amazing and of course it's all in color
as well which is even better if you
happen to be new around here well then
subscribe and check out the multitude of
different series that I've covered now
either way thank you all for 200,000
subscribers gain it's actually insane to
see how far we've come over the years
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate de Volo and I will see you
all in a bits bye